a regular site in Ueno siteís delivery
workers waiting outside restaurants
pharmacies and supermarkets willing to
deliver to you whatever you may need
Edgar Lucas has been living in one of
sizes for four years he's from Venezuela
and says that thanks to this job he can
send money back home every week I am
thankful to Argentina for giving me a
home I work 10 hours a day from Monday
to Monday it is non-stop bus it allows
me to make a look and delegate is not
alone as there are thousands of people
in Buenos Aires were making a living
like this these days as delivery apps
have become a showpiece for the
up-and-coming tech industry these new
delivery applications generate
much-needed jobs in a country like
argentina that it's going through an
economic crisis but labor unions
complain of poor safety standards a lack
of insurance coverage for workers that
they say are putting employees at risk
and that's why a judge suspended the ABS
on Friday he demanded companies should
pay for safety gear for those who work
for them
it's not clear when the ban will be
lifted net re radio is now working for
rappy he received a heart transplant six
years ago and says this is the only
place where he can work because most
companies won't hire him he works every
day and makes about five hundred dollars
a month we work for the companies
because it's the only thing we can find
but they make us pay for helmets clothes
backpack to take things in the end you
make very little money a few weeks ago a
delivery worker was run over by a car in
the message one of the company workers
asked him to take a picture of the
product he was carrying the man
responded he was unable to move and the
text message with a company went viral
because it had stains of blood labor
unions insist workers are being
exploited the
they're underpaid and have no benefits
we are trying to get these new apps to
respect the law we are not against them
or new technology but we need them to be
responsible for the people that work for
them they treat the delivery workers as
collaborators and they're not if they
work with the company someone should be
responsible the companies insist the
apps are meant to help people get extra
cash using digital platforms like ubirr
but in Latin America it has become a
main source of income that attracts
mostly vulnerable people with little
chances of standing up to defend their
rights para Tsavo
al Jazeera Buenos Aires